there is a big boom in private education
all over the world you see it in
schooling numbers so the numbers of
people going to private primary has gone
up from 10 to 17 percent over the last
15 years
secondaries gone up from 9 to 27 percent
and then if you look in particular
countries you find for instance in China
there's a big increase in people going
to elite private schools but also huge
business in terms of people getting
online tuition parents are finding ways
to spend money on the great competition
to improve their children's brains yes
hey the resurgence is happening for a
few different reasons and one of them is
that incomes are going up the birth
rates are going down
so in families all over the world there
is more money to spend on each child if
you look at the Chinese one-child policy
you get six people for grandparents two
parents all of them willing to invest in
the education of one child and at the
same time you've had the whole of the
world economy changing so that there are
fewer unskilled jobs everywhere almost
all decent jobs require you to have a
qualification of some sort so the great
advantage of private education is that
it's fantastically good at getting
children in school so in countries where
people are moving around a lot which is
most of the developing world and where
populations and growing swiftly well you
get this huge Swift urbanization
governments just can't keep up so you'll
get governments like Pakistan which you
know in Punjab which is a massive state
struggling with fast growing cities has
partnered up with the with the private
sector to send poor kids who would
otherwise not be getting schooling at
all into private schools and they're
doing that with over two million kids
and private schools can also be really
really good because you know often
parents are willing to spend masses of
money and you get a really high quality
of education it is a dilemma for society
governments need to concern themselves
about equality and about social mobility
things that the private sector
discourages rather than encourages the
problem with private schools is that
they do tend to increase inequality when
parents are allowed to spend money on
their children they will spend as much
as they can so obviously rich kids go to
better schools you see China which is
increasingly putting controls on the
expansion in the school's business it's
clearly pretty uncomfortable about it
rather than trying to shut it down
governments need to be trying to work
with it now there is a cost if you allow
the private sector to operate you are
going to get a higher level of
inequality but I think that that is a
price worth paying
for the Liberty for the resources for
the better brains for the innovation for
the quality of education and the breadth
of education that you get if you allow
the private sector to operate so I think
governments must look at the private
sector as a potential partner not as
they do in some places as an enemy